volevo chiederti scusa per quello che ho
fatto prima non ero in me stesso giuro
su dio che non volevo farti del male ma
dovevo sfogarmi in quel momento contro
qualcuno o qualcosa che mi sei capitato
tra le mani e ti fa ancora tanto male
spero che riuscirai a perdonarmi
questa recensione non volevo farla
albachiara è un film che dopo averlo
guardato ti lascia addosso una
sensazione di disgusto e terrore
e come quando assiste ad un incidente
stradale anche dopo che sono passati i
giorni
ripensandoci ti viene un brivido perché
questo non è il solito film italiano
brutto da quattro soldi albachiara e
pretenzioso e uno di quelli che cerca di
sfondare la monotonia dei film italiani
mettendo in luce i problemi dei giovani
in maniera proprio prepotente e questo è
un bene perché la gente che usa è sempre
la benvenuta
soprattutto in italia ma non è così che
si fa non in questo modo albachiara
vuole parlare di una cosa importante con
leggerezza e presunta ignoranza
se siete curiosi del motivo partiamo con
la trama del primo film recensito nel
[Musica]
il film inizia con il video di una
ragazza non credo di aver capito
ho fatto e mi ha messo poi missione in
egitto tra era talmente fatta che ok in
questo minuto e 25 secondi
scopriamo che alla protagonista piace
avere degli apparati genitali maschili
all'interno del suo cavo orale
vi chiedo come si evolva alla trama da
questo punto a notare la donna che
piange guardando il filmato tenetelo
bene a mente perché alla fine ci servirà
ma passiamo ad uno degli altri
protagonisti raz degan guardami mi
dovrei colpire forte ma non qui devo
cercare di non fare battute su mistero
devo riuscire a trattenersi sono gli
alieni in questo film l'assassino è un
uomo armato di ascia l'accento grazie
lega mi turba merda
il mitico razzo spiega i suoi scagnozzi
come mettere in pratica il piano che
vedremo più avanti
e siccome un film gigi giovane fatto per
i giovani riempiamolo di gag basate
sulla generalizzazione dei giovani
[Musica]
le suonerie imbecilli sui cellulari ma
uno dei quattro la ragazza non vuole
fare più il colpo o una scena quasi
decente peccato che sia una delle due
uniche scene quasi decenti una nota
particolare il film è pieno zeppo di
canzoni di vasco rossi che per motivi di
diritti non posso farvi sentire
conosciamo lo zio della protagonista che
lavora insieme allo scambio di prima
dalla suoneria ignorante hanno un
problema nel negozio desideri qualcosa
si serve caffè di solito allora si
solito ma non come l'altra volta come
scusa come non come l'altra volta non ti
capisco perché l'altra volta scatola
quasi vuota ti stai sbagliando sui dico
quasi vuota anche i miei biscotti e la
scatola sembrava sigilla e se ne
accorgono solo dopo averla comprata che
la busta e mezza vuota e finalmente
arriva alla nostra protagonista chiara
ho tolto l'audio perché appunto c'è
una canzone di vasco siccome ce ne
saranno molte faccio che sostituirle con
altre canzoni e facciamo prima raggiunge
lo zio che scopre che è stata lei ad
aprire e mangiare i prodotti questa
accesa quanto deve pesare questo invece
pesa quasi la metà 2 dopo che sugli
scaffali in vendita ancora faccio adesso
cambino quindi della serratura era
miseramente dall'altra parte sia chiaro
[Musica]
senti su un set
non ti chiedi di parlare con un [ __ ]
[Musica]
questa è l'idea che ha il regista di
film diretto ai ragazzi merda che appare
ovunque scrivendo robe colorate l'ho già
detto che massimo in giù giù giorni ed è
in ritardo per la scuola
[Musica]
[ __ ] a capo arrivata incontro al
bidello interpretato da stefano bicocchi
scelta peculiare riguarda lascia perdere
toni se non prenoto sono segata 8 lavoro
[Musica]
fatto di meglio fidati uhuru cosa accade
il film sta per caso avendo un attacco
cardiaco
ho fatto di meglio fidati li ho visti
entrare in biblioteca era solo
completamente solo e gli sono andata
dietro mi puoi dire le donne
dell'interrogazione di domani che te le
vette tutto
ma il senso di quegli intermezzi quale
di farmi incazzare lo tiene fuori ma che
credo ti giuro mi ha detto tutte le
domande e non solo dopo un bel lavoretto
capo ma l'hai vedete tutte le risme
steen e chiara chiara chiara ciao ti
conosco da poco più di dieci minuti e ti
voglio morta ma non morta all'improvviso
tipo infarto no non ho una di quelle
morti particolari tipo tipo che un
giorno viene morsa da un pipistrello e
diventi idrofoba il medico che ti ha in
cura si sbaglia
e invece di iniettarsi la morfina
vignetta dell'area etica usi un'embolia
polmonare dovuta da trombosi venosa
profonda ho esagerato un pochino
l'ironia vuole che la donna contro cui
ha sbattuto prima sia la sua nuova
professoressa di inglese e che quindi
cazzo sono in serata con fatto questo si
chiama karma stronza
facciamo la conoscenza della madre e
della sorella dichiara che sembra avere
qualche problema che il film non ci
spiega l'inutilità i due scagnozzi di
prima si preparano a fare il colpaccio
che consiste negli infiltrarsi in un
magazzino della polizia che sembra più
una centrale nucleare e rubare un carico
di droga
scopriamo anche che il razzo è un
detective corrotto ed ha pianificato lui
il tutto
signore pietà piccolissima nota
personale per il futuro se un giorno
iniziassi a ridere per queste gag
prendete un coltello e piantate melo nel
cuore grazie
nel frattempo la sorella pittrice sì
[Musica]
cosa starà mai succedendo se non capisco
io cosa sto guardando come faccia a
descrivere lo è come se il regista
avesse scoperto da poco after effects e
avesse deciso di buttarci dentro qualche
effetto speciale all'ultimo secondo
utile
intanto chiara e le sue due amiche sono
nel bagno di una discoteca terra che ve
ne pare così tanti punti
l'uomo deve sentire le labbra sopra
chiara mi raccomando non fare pompino sì
signore così bruttissimo destra o
sinistra sotto
magari ci fosse anche la lingua sopra
con la lingua
ok e avreste altri consigli per le
spettatrici che vorrebbero diventare
delle [ __ ] cioè come fa uno a
ritrovarsi a guardare un film del genere
al cinema geni tratto in inganno dal
fatto che un film per ragazzi lo vai a
vedere e rimane incastrato in questo
delirio abissale è una trappola è come
comprare un uovo di pasqua e trovare
come regalo il virus del vaiolo
ah già dimenticavo ci sono anche un
sacco di scene di nudo che mi tocca a
coprire con immagini di cani che si
leccano i testicoli sicuramente più
interessanti dell'intero film
intanto lo zio e la banda bassotti
portano tutta la droga rubata nel
magazzino del negozio dello stesso zio
ottima scelta logistica
[Musica]
io voglio morire
no ti prego tela confluire la borsa ma
ti prego abbandona la sfida ti scongiuro
io devo uccidere qualcuno
chi strozzo cosa ci faccio ancora qui a
guardare questa roba
io lo so che finiva così avrei mai
dovuto iniziare a fare video su youtube
lo sapevo
ora mi trovo a dover guardare questa
merda questo questo non è un film
questo è un tumore inoperabile che ti
porta alla morte
[Musica]
andiamo la mia amica no no no no no non
puoi passare da questo a questo andiamo
ad amarmi in meno di 10 secondi no
[Musica]
è bello immagini marzi trascinati dal
tempo c'è se io ti chiedessi tu cosa
provi per me non puoi farla diventare
una romanticona dopo averle fatto dire
questo spera che ve ne pare così tante
distinti non puoi andiamo avanti
io sono meno perché stanno a zero se
vedo una tanica che stavo bene ma lo
faccio quando fu la l'europa il mic è
morto qualcuno dimmi che è morto
qualcuno dimmi che è morto qualcuno
grazie
ora mi fermo due secondi per far
prendere aria al cervello e dirvi una
cosa buona parte della seconda metà di
film e futile sono molte scene una di
seguito all'altra montate soltanto per
arrivare a un'ora e mezza di film ve le
riassumo chiara piange lo zio si
riprende dalla botta chiara si riprende
e mangia la nutella raschia ma lo
scagnozzo ma non lo trova
viene chiamato da un tale k con una
musica che non c'entra nulla
[Musica]
e il compleanno del bidello chiara gli
preparo una torta ma al posto dello
zucchero filato ci mette per sbaglio la
cocaina del magazzino dello zio
purissima cassa c'è un altro detective
che sta indagando al caso della cocaina
scomparsa yara e il bidello scoprono
tutta la cocaina e decidono di venderla
per farsi soldi rallentiamo un po il
ragazzo dichiara interpretato dal vero
figlio di vasco rossi decide insieme a
due amiche di fare soldi facili aprendo
un sito di pornografia in streaming
porno must.net e questo è il numero
degli utenti collegati
avete presente non quello che tutti i
giovani fanno masse e giù giù giù con e
via di montaggi musicali porno soft
sessi che dei sexy
pereira al consigliere era ho dovuto
censurare tutto perché era una scena di
sesso con vasco in sottofondo quindi
ecco una coincidenza strana la
professoressa d'inglese abita proprio
sotto chiara e per un incidente con dei
tubi si ritrovano loro due e il bidello
a fumare canne e a registrare
confessioni sessuali che guarda caso la
scena iniziale del film infatti la donna
che piange e proprio la prof
ma tenete l'ancora mente perché ci
servirà alla fine
[Musica]
ancora sta roba datemi una spiegazione
non potete mettere effetti speciali ad
minchiam solo perché sono belli da
vedere dio santo chiara il ragazzo è il
bidello decidono di fare un mega rave
per riuscire a vendere un po della
cocaina allora la crisi la jessica
ecco il nostro favini altra [ __ ] gilet
bene e giuro su dio
le scene del rave solo infinite durano
tipo cinque minuti ma sembrano quattro
ore e mezza
ho capito è pieno di gente che vive
scopa basta già dimenticavo c'è spazio
anche per la mora in questa melma
radioattiva quando ci sei mi accorgo che
se non ci sei mi manchi sto vomitando la
mattina scopriamo che il mega rave è
stato fatto in un hangar di una pista di
atterraggio
anti sgamo proprio infatti razze lo
scopre e riesce a risalire al fidanzato
di chiara
ti prego fa che non lo so lo rapisca e
lo torturi tipo hostel male dove sono i
miei 200 chili ma vuole coca ma che
cazzo adesso hai risposto male ma se ti
adoro se il nostro salvatore bello da
casa
vasco junior viene fatto fuori grazie
trash trova chiara che lo porta al
magazzino e quando pensi che tutto il
film ormai sia andato allo sfacelo raz
degan lo salva con una sola frase
[Musica]
finisco il tempo delle mele razze è
appena diventato il mio attore italiano
preferito così a caso ma c'è poco da
festeggiare
dopo i titoli di coda c'è un'altra scena
in cui si vede il razzo legato ad una
sedia il libro di shakespeare della
professoressa d'inglese e qualcuno gli
spara io vi uccido tutti non potevate
lasciare il finale con lo sparo è la
frase [ __ ] e basta no ci doveva per
forza mette in una roba a caso che non
fa altro che confondere la trama già di
per sé orrenda grazie mille
[Musica]
un po a sinistra sotto magari ci fosse
anche la lingua sopra io non ho parole
questo è uno dei punti più bassi della
cinematografia italiana secondo me un
film che tenta disperatamente di essere
originale ma fallisce alla base ripeto
sono contento che si cerchi di cambiare
anche se il film ormai è del 2006
ma porca eva che schifo sono molti film
che parlano di ragazzi che fanno uso di
droghe
basti vedere cose come trainspotting o
requiem for a dream
ma sono di tutt'altro livello
l'argomento lì viene trattato in modo
crudo realistico proprio un pugno allo
stomaco e così deve essere qui è
involontariamente ridicolo
sembra che basti far vedere due tette
dei ragazzi che si drogano e un
poliziotto corrotto per fare un film
ribelle sono arrivato ad un limite non
ne posso più quindi scusa assieme la
sono presa con te ma sto film era
proprio fate girare che poi come abbiamo
fatto a ridurre il cinema italiano in
questo stato soldi può essere ma non
riesco a capire perché i soldi debbano
necessariamente toglie le idee non
possono coesistere idee soldi boh
aimi su l'ultimo video di victor maslow
parla proprio di questo
xavier limiti rimetto a posto dai